[Music]
if we were to summarize the main plot of
philip k dick's novel to android's dream
of electric sheep and
also the blade runner the film
adaptation of it it would be along these
lines rick deckard bounty hunter has to
chase down
six androids masking themselves as human
beings who
will try to kill him as he tries to kill
them so
what's going on here deckard is a bounty
hunter he gets paid his entire job
is hunting down andes or androids who
are becoming more and more sophisticated
in passing themselves off as humans
they're not supposed to be on earth but
they come back to earth in part because
they want to get away from their bad
lives out in the colonies where they are
at best you know very valued tools and
at worst slave labor
so
our story begins with deckard getting to
step into
the job as senior bounty hunter because
the the previous senior bounty hunter
dave holden
was able to retire two of the eight
escaped androids and then was not quite
done in but certainly taken out of
commission
by the
third one so we begin here in chapter
three learning about these
as deckard unlocks his office story
superior police inspector harry bryant
says meet me at 9 30 in dave holden's
office and then he tells him holden is
in mount zion hospital with a laser
track through his spine he'll be there
for a month at least until they can get
a hold of one of those new organic
plastic spinal sections to take hold and
rick says well what happened uh the
department's chief bounty hunter had
been all right yesterday at the end of
the day he'd zipped off at his hover car
to his apartment
bryant muttered something over his
shoulder and then he hears his secretary
anne marston say mr deckard you know
what happened to mr holden he got shot
he says yeah it must have been one of
those new ever
extra clever andes the rosen association
is turning out and so this is setting
the the framework for what's going on
new more challenging androids that have
to be dealt with a little bit later
bryant is saying to deckard this is the
first time you'll be acting as senior
bounty hunter dave knows a lot he's got
years of experience behind him and then
rick says well so do i and then brian
clarifies you've handled assignments
devolving to you from dave's schedule
he's always decided
exactly which ones to turn over to you
and which not to but now you've got six
he intended to retire himself one of
which managed to get him first this one
max polikov that's what it calls itself
anyhow assuming
dave was right everything is based on
that assumption
this entire list and yet the voigt camp
altered scales only been administered to
the first three the two dave retired and
then palakkoff it was while dave was
administering the test that's when
polikov lasered him and rick says okay
well that proves that he was right
otherwise he wouldn't have been lasered
polikov would have no motive and then
deckard is going to be sent off to the
rosen association to try out the test
ultimately on rachel rosen and then
he'll come back and start taking up this
assignment retire
six androids and he decides to begin
with polikov who is the one who nearly
killed his colleague and
who's probably been alerted to what's
going on so he's like well this is the
one we we probably
need to deal with uh the first and so he
goes to uh polikoff's
work the bay area scavengers company and
why is pollock off there he's pretending
to be what's called an ant head one of
the
worst off of the specials deteriorated
mentally
as it turns out polikov might be one of
the sharpest
of the bunch
and
[Music]
deckard goes to his work he's not there
he hasn't been there
um you know he presents his id where is
your employee at his job or at home
and the person says paula cough ought to
be at work flattening hover cars that
are daily city plant dumping them into
the bay
however he's not then
he said terminating the call polikov
didn't show up to work today no
explanation so deckard goes to his
apartment and lands on the roof he says
what a grimy place by elevator he
descends to polikov's floor found the
hall on lit like a subterranean cave
using his police a powered sealed beam
light he illuminated the hall once again
glanced over the onion skin carbon the
trans the duplicate right the voigt camp
test had been administered that part
could be bypassed and so he sets up a
wave transmitter uh you know somewhat
like the mood organ except on a larger
scale
and punches a key for catalepsy making
everybody else in the building frozen
stiff everyone human and andy alike in
the vicinity no risk to me all i have to
do is walk in and laser him so he goes
in and no pollock off there either right
only semi ruined furniture a place of
kipple
and decay so he goes up to the roof
and um
he uh uh is now going to move on to the
next one
uh luba luft but
there's uh somebody who's supposed to be
coming in from the
soviet uh police agency
and um they're you know waiting for for
him and he shows up
so
here we go mr deckard uh uh he
approaches at asking with a slavic
accent the bounty hunter for the san
francisco police department the empty
taxi rose the russian watched it go i'm
sander kadali the man said and open the
car door to squeeze in beside rick and
rick figures out that this isn't sandor
kadali there actually isn't a police
officer coming
from the
soviet union
and their police
he says to him and he's got sort of a
slip of the tongue you're not polikov
you're kiddali and then the android says
to him don't you mean the other way
around you're a bit confused i mean
you're polikov the android you're not
from the soviet police and rick presses
the emergency button on the floor of his
car which means that the laser tube
won't fire
and he starts to go after him physically
i'll have to break your pencil neck and
he grabs both hands for rick's throat as
the android's hand sank into his throat
rick fired his regulation issue old
style pistol from its shoulder holder
the slug struck the android in the head
and its brain box burst the nexus 6 unit
which operated it blew into pieces of
raging mad wind which carried throughout
the car bits of it like the radioactive
dust itself whirled down on rick the
retired remains of the android rock back
collided with the car door bounced off
and struck heavily against him he found
himself struggling to shove the
twitching remnants of the android away
so then he calls in and says i've got
the first one i've got polycov
now polycroft is an interesting
uh person so he's posing
both as
a special and as this guy sandor cadali
and a little bit later
we get a take on paulakoff that
could be true or could just be uh
there to lead us
off the trail
and it's uh when he's in in the the fake
police station
talking with um garland who is the next
one
on his his uh thing and so he um
he says uh
this is garland talking about polikov
you know where i guessed wrong i didn't
know about polikov he must have come
here earlier obviously he came here
earlier in another group entirely no
contact with ours he was already
entrenched in the wpo when i arrived i
took a chance on the lab report which i
shouldn't
polikov was almost my finish too rick
says and then he says yeah there was
something
about him i don't think he could have
been the same brain unit type as we
he must have been souped up or tinkered
with an altered structure unfamiliar
even to us a good one too
almost good enough so there's something
unusual at least from the android's
perspective
to this particular android polikov we
move on to the next one garland garland
is listed on rick's
things that he's gotten from dave holden
the sheets as being an insurance
underwriter but he's actually a police
inspector in the
fake
mission street police department that is
infested as rick says with androids and
so now he's uh posing in that way and
he's got androids working for him the
harness bull for example who rick isn't
gonna do anything with because he's not
on his list even though he is an android
who's not supposed to be there
and he's suggesting to his own
um
colleague his own subordinate
that he's an android uh once once they
they
start revealing these things if he
actually suggests it to deckart that
phil rash is going to be really really
upset
phil rush of course turns out not to be
an android and actually to be a rather
unusual
bounty hunter so rick is going to also
do in
garland and garland reveals a bit more
information to him all of this is
happening
with the garland stuff as a result of
going after libel luft libba luft
is another escaped android who is posing
as an opera singer and who is good
enough to be singing
opera
she has a genuine flair for it
and you know rick even feels kind of bad
about
all of this
you know that he's watching a rehearsal
and um
he's you know sort of mulling things
over and and uh
he actually realizes that he's part of
the form destroying process of entropy
of the rosen association creates an eye
on make
and he
studies uh libel luft right reading the
sheet of information a little ironic the
sentiment her role calls for however
vital active and nice looking and
escaped android could hardly tell the
truth about itself anyhow on the stage
libeloff saying and he found himself
surprised at the quality of her voice it
rated with that of the best even of the
notables in his collection of historic
tapes the rosen association had built
her well he had to admit and again he
perceived himself subspecie eternitates
or the spanosian phrase the form
destroyer called forth by what he heard
and saw here perhaps the better she
functions the better a singer she is the
more i'm needed if the androids had
remained remained substandard like the
ancient q40s made by doraen associates
there would be no problem and no need of
my skill and then he begins doing the
voigt camp test with her and she finds
ways to subvert it
holds a laser tube on him calls the
police that gets him to garland station
where eventually garland and phil resh
will shoot it out and so deckard isn't
actually killing garland it's it's phil
rush who kills him and we can say the
same thing about luba luft because phil
rush not quite sure if he's an android
or not
quite worried about it goes with decker
to
go after lebel luft and
phil resh antagonized by liboluft
suggesting that he's an android himself
lasers her
in the elevator and there's a lot of
back and forth there about
the
empathy that
uh deckard begins feeling
for level luft and for androids
more
generally
so those are the three
of those three
only one is killed by deckard but he
gets to collect all three bounties then
there's the other three pris stratton
who we encounter very early on
in connected with isidore she
moves into
his building and actually what she tells
him is in chapter six originally
he asks um
you know uh he says did you get my name
john isadore and she says yeah you work
for hannibal sloat who i'm sure doesn't
exist outside of your imagination
my name is she gave him one last
warmthless glance as she returned to her
apartment hesitated and said
i'm rachel rosen now rachel rosen is
another
android who plays a major role within
this work right and priss is not rachel
but priss is made along the same lines
as rachel as we learn later on
so isidore says of the rosen association
the system's largest manufacturer of
humanoid robots used in our colonization
program and then a complicated
expression instantly crossed her face
fleetingly gone at once no i never heard
of them i don't know anything about it
more of your chicken had imagination i
suppose john is the door in his personal
private empathy box poor mr isidore but
your name suggests and then she says my
name
is pris
stratton that's my married name i always
use it i never use any other name then
priss you can call me pris no you better
address me as miss stratton because we
don't really
know each other so that's her
and she holds up with isidore and gets
the word out to the two other remaining
androids irmgard and roy beatty and we
find
that
they you know come to the apartment
and in chapter 14
roy says can we talk indicating isidore
pris vibrant with bliss said it's okay
up to a point to isadora she said excuse
us she led the babies on off to one side
and muttered at them the three of them
returned to confront mr isidor who felt
uncomfortable and out of place and they
began talking and he's going to realize
that their androids after a short amount
of time
then they're they're asking or they're
talking with each other about
their
their android
uh
companions you could call them
so roy beatty says they got paula cough
the joy which had appeared on chris's
face at seeing her friends melted away
who else
they got garland roy beatty said they
got anders and gitchell and then just a
little earlier today they got luba so
anders and gitzel were retired by dave
holden
the other three by either deckard or
deckard and phil rush
um i didn't think that good lobba
remember i kept saying that during the
trip so that leaves pris says the three
of us irmgard said with apprehensive
urgency that's why we're here roy
beatty's voice boomed out with
unexpected warmth
and then they go on they had this
investigator this bounty hunter erim
guard said in agitation named dave
holden
and polikov almost got him almost got
him roy echoed his smile now immense so
he's in this hospital this holden and
evidently they gave his list to another
bounty hunter and polikov almost got him
too but it wound up with him retiring
paulakoff then he went after libba we
know that because she managed to get
hold of garland and he sent out someone
to capture the bounty hunter and take
him to the mission street building luba
called us after garland's agent picked
up the bounty hunter she was sure it
would be okay she was sure garland would
kill him but evidently something went
wrong on mission we don't know what
perhaps we never will then chris asks
does this bounty hunter have our names
oh yes dear i suppose he does zimgard
said but he doesn't know where we are
roy and i aren't going back to our
apartment we have as much stuff in our
cars we can cram in and we've decided to
take one of the these abandoned
apartments in this ratty old building so
that is them establishing themselves uh
bringing each other up to speed
and they're going to stick together as a
strategy they think that it was probably
too risky to be out there trying to pass
in society as the other androids were
going to do there is one other thing to
bring up which is that roy beatty
himself
is somewhat of a
false messiah type we get in the
um information sheet roy beatty has an
aggressive assertive heir of his
authority given to mystical
preoccupations this android proposed the
group escape attempt underwriting it
ideologically with a pretentious fiction
and as to the sacredness of so-called
android life in addition this android
stole and experimented with various
mind-fusing drugs claiming when caught
that it hoped to promote an android's a
group experience similar to that of
mercerism which it pointed out remains
unavailable to androids and rick deckard
is reflecting on this uh this pharmacist
who roy beatty was right and the account
had a
pathetic quality a rough cold android
hoping to undergo an experience from
which due to a deliberately built-in
defect it remained excluded
he could not work up much concern for
roy beatty he caught from dave's
jottings a repellent quality hanging
about this particular android beatty had
tried to force the fusion experience
into existence for itself and when that
fell through it engineered the killing
of a variety of human beings
followed by the flight to
earth
now
there's another take on beatty which is
that he's you know
he's the real deal
and we're going to see this
with rachel rosen after she seduces or
allows herself to be seduced because
clearly deckard has a desire for her
they have sex and then she says you're
not going to be able to keep hunting
androids but that's okay you know why
because this trip we're taking won't be
wasted
you're going to meet
a wonderful spiritual man
roy beatty he said do you know all of
them
i knew all of them when they still
existed i know three now we tried to
stop you this morning before you started
out with dave holden's list i tried
again just before paula cough reached
you but then after that
i had to wait and she goes on and says
louis lyft and i had been close very
close friends for almost two years
what did you think of her
did you like her i liked her but you
killed her phil resh killed her oh okay
now now we
know that and
so rachel is revealing that she not only
knows these androids but she thinks that
roy beatty was in fact you know a great
man a great person
and
all three of these these final ones
chris stratton who's the most difficult
one because she looks like rachel
for whom deckard has very conflicted
feelings
he's able to kill her mercer actually
helps out with that and then he shoots
irmgard and then he shoots roy beatty we
don't have anything like what happens in
the blade runner movie instead it's
actually much more methodical and
one-sided and this winds up becoming a
record
carried out by this
newly promoted
chief bounty hunter right uh deckard who
gets to step into the role of dave
holden after dave holden uh fails and is
is lasered by max polikov he does in all
of these six androids and it produces a
massive
reflection change
a metanoia
you know
a turning of the soul within him and he
probably won't be able to continue after
this but
that brings the plot essentially
to a close at least as far as the
hunting
the killers hunting the
hunters hunting the androids goes
you